so in both cases the question is just
solve for X okay sulfur X and you can
see in this case why obviously it's
going to be a quadratic so what should I
write him first
yeah okay so I'm gonna go ahead and be a
little lazy Q because we're snow sort of
getting to the point where this is not a
proof or a question really about
Pythagoras it's really about quadratics
okay that's again that's what's really
being assessed okay but that's fine it's
true that's your starting point
naturally the equation I'm gonna write
out of that year something like this so
this is my quadratic so far so good
and now kind of autopilot takes over
might actually expand here so okay well
you tell me what this expansion is
excellent okay and let's see shopping he
told me the dick right hand side
excellent okay so no big deal bit of
routine canceling to do so I've got next
square here x squared there what else
should I do really quickly
I've got X's over here right you can see
this is not just going to simply cancel
out I'm going to need to collect my like
terms and I'm what them all on the same
side don't I okay so I'm gonna breed
these guys over it also get a bring this
guy involved right so that'll leave me
with my last slide which is x squared
minus comedy X 18 X that's why we do
these right 49 I'm gonna have to take
away 4 from both sides so I get 4 you
look carefully does it factorize nicely
does it factor as I said it's not a
common one our brains immediately go
five and nine laughs again okay but
clearly there's more there right fifteen
and three so I'm gonna need two what's
my expansion good thing X minus three X
minus 15 so now I have two solutions
that look right and if I'm positive
we're looking at legs right oh good yeah
no no not all good something is wrong
what's gone wrong okay so I need to
check for negatives right mostly
everyone was kind of like yeah all right
I don't see anything negative here but
there is a negative where's the negative
there is gotcha right okay so this is
where we have to be careful this is why
I picked this question out which gives
you a bit of a clue that's what's gonna
happen here this is not a solution this
is not a solution these are both
solutions to this right but these are
not both solutions to this because this
implies hey um this implies a rejection
doesn't it so in fact what I should have
done before I even wrote this down I
should have looked at this and this
should have told me a restriction namely
at the very least right this shouldn't
be any other money you know obviously
you want these two positives so but
that's kind of a given right this is
really your sneaky one okay because it
looks okay but it's not really okay so
at this point I would invoke the
restriction that I noted earlier I'd say
this therefore X is 15 only okay so I've
given you a bit of a warm-up so you
should be a little more klouey when it
comes to this one yeah this does not
take much to solve what should I do to
every term I shouldn't multiply through
by something which will eliminate all
the fractions which looks to me like X X
minus 2 yeah so in this case you're just
going to simply wipe off the denominator
in this case you're going to be left
with X minus 2 on the numerator and
likewise you're just going to get an X
over there okay well expand a little bit
for X minus 8 equals 5x now tell me what
to do I can do a bit of I mean yeah I
mean to keep everything nice and neat
and positive I'll just keep the
constants over here and I'll bring the X
over there
therefore no solution what right good
again like I said you got clued in right
before you start to soul before you
write down any working North the
restrictions restrictions first okay
before you do any working because by the
time you embark on your working you
forget about the restrictions
particularly if you're in a hurry and
you're under exam pressure these are the
kinds of things to catch you so right up
here before I started working I should
have said X can't equal to zero X can't
equal to two and there's my restriction
right this is always a safer way to go
about it than to do your working and
then count on yourself to remember oh
I'd better check if this works or not
right get it right from the outset and
then when you arrive you'll be expecting
you
you're anticipated can I just say as I
was mentioning you know a yard when you
get an assessment the assessments are
crafted by us to assess whether you can
actually watch out for things like this
right so even though these kinds of
questions will not commonly come up in
in in exercise you know this one dies
this one doesn't it right but that's
because they're exercises they're like
standard questions assessments are
designed to sift people out and work out
what's the difference between can you
can you do the algebra but can you go
further and know that there are
restrictions in place these are called
extraneous solutions because they are
solutions that that's actually extra
outside of what is what makes sense in a
situation you've been provided okay so
if you want to label for them that's
what they call and they're bad
so notice them